so the first talk is by uh um
shivam about quantitative correlation
inequalities via semi-group
interpolation
yeah thanks avishai and thank you all
for sticking around for the last session
of today
so this is joint work with an india and
rocco
um and and it's about correlation
inequalities
so let me start off by telling you what
a correlation inequality is
you've got some probabilities based and
you're interested in some
familiar functions on this probability
space and a correlation inequality
simply tells you that
any two functions belonging to this
family are non-negatively correlated
and these are very fundamental tools in
combinatorics and statistical physics
if you if you grab your copy of colon
and spencer you'll find in full chapter
devoted to
these sorts of statements to make things
a little more concrete let's look at
perhaps the simplest correlation
inequality the harris kleitman
inequality
which says that any two monotone boolean
functions on the n-dimensional hypercube
are not negatively correlated
so just to remind everyone the
n-dimensional hypercube is the
collection of zero one strings of length
n and a function is set to be monotone
if flipping a bit from zero to one
cannot cause the value of the function
to decrease
another correlation inequality is
rhoyans in a quantity this was proved in
2014
and it concerns symmetric convex sets of
a gaussian space
by gaussian space i just mean rn end up
with the standard gaussian distribution
and a set is symmetric if it's symmetric
about the origin or in other words if a
point x is in the set
the point obtained by reflecting x
through the origin or in other words
flipping the sign of each of nexus
coordinates is also in the set
and what range showed is that if you've
got two symmetric convex sets
then the indicator functions of these
two sets are non-negatively correlated
with respect to the standard gaussian
distribution
another way of stating rhoyn's result is
as follows it simply says that the
gaussian measure of the intersection
of two symmetric convex sets is at least
the product of the gaussian measures of
the sets themselves
and there's many other correlation
inequalities for interesting clusters of
functions on different domains but since
you only have eight minutes let's focus
on the two
two examples we just saw so one thing to
note about both of these statements is
that they're qualitative statements
all they say is that this this
correlation between these two functions
is non-negative
and it's natural to hope for a for a
better lower bound on this correlation
perhaps in terms of some property of the
functions we're looking at
so with this in mind let's actually
revisit the the harris kleitmann
inequality
and when you're thinking about boolean
functions perhaps the first property
that comes to mind
is the notion of influence so this is a
very standard notion
um given a boolean function on the
n-dimensional hypercube
you can define the influence of any of
its n-coordinates say the i-coordinate
as the probability that when you choose
a point uniformly at random from the
from the boolean hypercube the value of
f at that point
differs from the value of f at the point
obtained by flipping the ith bit
of the original point and this this
influence captures in some sense
how much the function depends on the i
coordinate and there's been a very long
line of very interesting work built
around this notion of influence and we
saw some
um some new proofs that the results are
mentioned just in yesterday's analytic
method session
so returning to correlation inequalities
in 1996 telegram proved the following
robust version
of the harris clietman inequality you
showed that if you've got two monotone
boolean functions
you can lower bound the correlation in
terms of this function psi
of the sum of the products of the
influences of the two functions
and this the sum of the products of
these influences it captures in some
sense
how much the two functions depend
simultaneously on the same set of
coordinates
and this quantity actually arises very
naturally in the proof of the harris
kleitmann inequality itself
so it's not very surprising and this
functions high of x is just defined to
be x over log of
e over x so to summarize the situation
so far we've got these two
nice qualitative statements that have
slightman inequality and
the gaussian correlation and equality or
random quality and telegram comes along
and robustifies the expression on the
left
and you know you've got this really
interesting quantitative correlation in
the quantity now
for monotone boolean functions and it's
natural to hope for a similar statement
for
symmetric convex sets of gaussian space
but if not a similar statement
some quantitative version of ryan's
result and that's precisely what we
obtained in this work
we show that given two symmetric convex
sets
you can lower bound the correlation
between them in terms of this function
phi of the sum of the products of these
influences
and this function feed differs from
telegram's psi function in that it's got
an additional logarithmic factor in the
denominator
but i also haven't told you what this
this notion of influence for
a symmetrical convex set is so let me
briefly define that
um it's a little it might be a little
technical so if you've got a symmetric
convex set
um the influence in the eighth direction
of the
set is the negated degree to her meat
coefficient
so for those who are familiar with
boolean functional analysis the hermit
basis
is sort of similar to the parity basis
for
functions on the hypercube but it's a
basis for functions of a gaussian space
and it's up and these coefficients are
sort of analogous to the degree one
fourier coefficients of the boolean
function
and if you're not familiar with it just
think of it as this expectation of the
indicator function
with this this polynomial 1 minus x i
squared scaled by root 2.
and this this notion of influence really
does behave
like a notion of influence in particular
it's not negative
with equality if and only if this the
symmetric convex set k
is independent of the i coordinate
in other words it's sort of a cylinder
along the ith direction
and many other interesting analogies
with you know similar results from
boolean function
analysis seem to hold for this new
notion of influence and we've been
exploring this notion further
so returning to the the quantitative
correlation inequality that we prove
um suppose kl are two symmetric sets
we know that the value of the
expectation of k times l is greater than
the value of the expectation of k
times the expectation of l because of
roy's inequality
and what we do is we actually
interpolate between these two quantities
um and there's a natural way of doing
this by starting with
you know the quantity on top and adding
noise to one of the two functions
and you eventually had an enough noise
that this noisy version of say k
becomes independent of l and this
expectation splits into the expectation
of k times the expectation of l
so let's introduce this noise parameter
rho and row is small you should think of
very nice the noise rate being very high
and when row is large
close to one we're adding very little
noise and
suppose we interplayed using this noise
noisy process that i described more
formally it's given by this one
standalone back noises operator
and we get this this curve that looks
like this now
the hermite basis lets us write this
curve as a power series
in rho and our main technical lemma is
this complex analytic tool
which essentially tells you that the
value of this power series at some point
along this interpolation is large
but this isn't enough to conclude that
the correlation is large because
you know the the value of the the curve
at the right end point might be
much lower than the the supreme of this
curve
um and so let's actually ask roy and
what he thinks of the situation so yes
drawing he's looking at this this curve
i put up and he's clearly not very happy
because what he actually shows is that
this interpolation has to be monotone
in other words the curve is going to
look something like this and this
monotonicity lets us actually conclude
that the correlation is going to be
large and so let me put this
this whole this the sketch of a proof um
a little more abstractly
you've got some probability space and
some familiar functions you're
interested in
and you can interpolate between the two
terms in this correlation quantity
uh by means of some appropriately
defined markov sami group
now once you've got this interpolation
you can express it as a power series
using the elegant functions of this
markov semi group
and our complex analytic lemma tells you
that the value of this power series is
large somewhere along this interpolation
and finally this monotonicity of this
interpolation let's just conclude that
the correlation is large and this
monotonicity is often available
in the form of off-the-shelf results so
people prove this monitoring ect to
prove qualitative statements
so this lets us obtain quantitative
correlation inequalities in a bunch of
different interesting domains
by choosing an appropriate markov semi
group and there doesn't seem to be a
canonical choice to mark of semi group
to put on some of these domains
for example on the on the solid cube for
each
different choices of markov semi group
we get a seemingly different
quantitative coordination inequality
so here's a quick summary of everything
i just described longer video is up on
youtube and the full version of the
paper is an
thanks archive watching
thank you for the great talk um
wonderful result
okay so maybe um should stop sharing
screen and we should
move to the next speaker and you and you
know it's good if you have a quick
question you can
ask no
okay so maybe we'll leave the questions
for later
and next we have um
sacha golovnev talking about circuit
depth reductions
yeah hi everyone uh thank you for
watching yeah my name is sasha gamif and
this is a joint work with sasha kulikov
and ryan williams
uh in this work we suggest a new way for
proven circuit lower bonds
so we do not prove any new circuit lower
bound but in particular we show
how improvements on the known
constructions of various pseudo-random
objects
would lead via our framework to new
circuit lower parts
okay so first let me remind you the
computational model we're going to be
talking about this is a model of boolean
circuits
here we want to compute a function from
n bits to one bit
and we're computed it by this directed
acyclic graph that is called the circuit
and this graph has n inputs and every
gate computes
a boolean function of two boolean inputs
okay and we do not pose any restrictions
on the outer ground fan out of gates
all right so a simple counts in argument
show and the size of the circuit is just
the number of gates in it
and the simple counts and argument shows
that most of the functions require
circuits of exponential size
but the challenge is to find an explicit
function stay function from the class
and p
that is hard for circuits that cannot be
computed by a small circuit
this is the problem of circuit lower
bounds
so even if we prove a super polynomial
just super polynomial our bound for a
function from np we separate p from np
so even though we know that most of the
functions uh have exponential complexity
we actually need to only improve super
polynomial r1
and the best what we can do is roughly
3n even if we are trying to prove
circuit lower balance for functions from
a much larger complexity class
the class of exponential time algorithms
with an np oracle
that and this empirical in turn can even
take inputs of exponential size
so even for huge classes the best
circuit lower bound we can proof is
roughly 3n
and so when we can't prove
a lower bond for a computational model
we usually consider a weaker
weaker models so here a natural special
case
is the class of circuits of boundary
depth
so say if the depth of a circuit is just
two
then such a circuit can only compute
cnfs or dns
and this essentially is the only circuit
model that we understand well for
example we know that even the parity
function very explicit function
would require such circuits of
exponential size
but even if the depth is three for any
other constant we still know how to
prove exponential
exponential uh circuit level
now if the depth is logarithmic say 1.9
log n
and every gate again computes
a function of 2 of two inputs
then we know functions that are hard and
this in this model that cannot be
computed by circuits of depth one point
nine log n
but already for depth tool again we know
nothing we know nothing on tl again the
best socket lower bound is roughly 3
so the main problem on the front here
is proving anything better as a super
linear lower bound
at least for log depth circuits
all right so and why why is this problem
so hard because
essentially the only technique that we
know for proven circuit lower bonds
in this models of high
high depth is the technique called gate
elimination
and it's bad for several reasons um this
gate elimination is always ugly case
analysis we don't want to do this
and also probably it cannot lead to
interest in circuit laurens gate
elimination cannot give us anything
better than say 5n
which is clearly not not that exciting
okay so we desperately need new
techniques for proven circuit lower
bound something
uh different from gate elimination in
this work we suggest
one such technique it doesn't lead to
new super uh new
circuit lower balance immediately but
hopefully maybe some time later
but uh first i want to say that in the
70s valent already gave
an interest in non-gate elimination
technique for pruning circuit lower
bounds
but for special case of circuits for
circuits of logarithmic depth
namely in this in the 70s when it showed
that every circuit of linear size and
logarithmic depth
can be computed by a non-trivial depth 3
circuit by a depth 3 circuit of
sub-exponential size so
if you prove a strong exponential lower
bound
for depth 3 circuits it translates to
super linear lower bound
even for long depth circuits
all right so uh valiant reduces the
depth of a circuit from
order of log n to three and his proof we
use a circuit as a graph
so it never looks at what is computed in
this uh at every node of a circuit but
it views it as a graph and it's known
that such
graph theoretic techniques cannot work
for
circuits of super logarithmic depth
so the first result of this work um we
show
that we also do depth reduction for
circuits of
unbounded depth but unfortunately only a
small size of size roughly 4a
okay so the first result of this work is
depth reduction
for even unbounded depth circuits but
only of size
uh roughly 4m every unbounded depth
circuits s can be computed by the
following depth
circuit and this is interesting when the
original size is less than 3.9
so again a random function cannot be
computed by such a depth 3 circuit
and we show that
any improvement that improvements of the
known pseudorandom objects
on the known constructions of
pseudorandom objects would also lead to
the circuit lower bound form boundary
depth circuits
also we prove a similar result from
bounded depths linear circuits and
matrix regions it will show a new
connection between the student
finally we apply uh our framework for
two demorgan formulas so a formula is a
circuit where
our degree of every gate is exactly one
you cannot reuse
computation and demorgan formula means
that
you cannot use xor gates on the ends or
some knots
a long line of very beautiful works
leads to an essentially cubic layer of
bound
on demorgan formulas
and in this um in this work using this
depth reduction framework
we give a way of studying demorgan
formulas
of size and to the fourth
all right that's it thank you for your
attention i'll be happy to take any
questions either now
or at the end of the session
okay thank you very much sasha for a
great talk
i think we have a time for like uh one
or two questions
uh one while uh ben sets up
what is the plausible assumption in your
life yeah yeah unfortunately i didn't
have time to cover it uh so uh in short
and says the poland that
uh a demorgan formula of size s has a
probabilistic polynomial
of degree square root of s so we know
that it has
approximate polynomial over the reals of
degree square root of s
we would like to say that it also has a
probabilistic polynomial say over 2
db thank you
thank yeah you so
maybe let's continue to the next talk
uh by uh ben rossmann a shrinkage of
decision lists and dnfs
all right so um uh so i'll start by
defining the
models that we consider so dnf formulas
we're all familiar with so
um we have a disjunction of conjunctive
clauses so each clause
or term uh is just a conjunction of
literals
so a decision list of size m is a
sequence of
m clauses and and m
output values where the disjunction of
c1 to cm
is a dnf tautology so it's true on all
on all inputs so and without loss of
generality the
final clause could just be the empty
clause which is always true
uh and here we let you know the
output values can be anything not
necessarily boolean valued
and a decision list computes a function
uh by simply
outputting the i output value if
where i is the index of the first
satisfied clause
okay so i'll also be discussing decision
lists
sorry decision trees and demorgan
formulas
um yeah we're all familiar with the
definitions here
okay so for function f on the hypercube
we can define its decision tree size and
its decision list size
and in the case of boolean functions we
also have dnf
formula size as measured by number of
clauses and de morgan formula leaf size
denoted lf
okay so decision lists are a
generalization they're more powerful
model than decision trees
so you know for any function is decision
list size is is at most its decision
tree size
for boolean functions we see that
decision lists are sort of more powerful
than both dnfs and cnfs
which which which uh are more powerful
than decision trees
and we also have um width or depth
versions
uh of all of these size measures
and these satisfy the inequalities that
you see below
okay so the the p random restriction
we're all familiar with also so this is
a
random assignment partial assignment of
the variables where
a variable is left free with probability
p otherwise set to zero or one with
equal
probability and uh right so for
an invariable function we get this
randomly restricted function
so it's well known that the p random
restriction reduces
the the complexity of boolean functions
as as measured by
uh these simple complexity measures
i i forgot to start my timer so
obviously i just let me know when i'm
when i have a minute or two left
okay so um uh right so
so the classic result on the on
on the effect of rp on on
these simple complexity measures the
shrinkage of demorgan formulas
so um uh so
so it's known that the expected uh
formula size
of a boolean function under rp shrinks
like p
squared okay by a factor like a p
squared
and yeah we saw a very nice
generalization of this
of this result earlier in the in the
conference to a more general class of
random restrictions
um so another result showing the power
of uh
of of rp uh on this time on dnf or cnf
formulas is the switching lemma
right so this shows that a small width
dnf formula converts to a
small width c and f formula uh with with
uh
with high probability
okay so um so here on this slide i state
the results in this paper so
we look at shrinkage of um of uh
decision lists and decision trees
uh and the results are as follows so for
decision trees
you can show that the expected decision
tree size
uh shrinks much faster than than any
like than any
uh constant depending on p but rather
shrinks like the decision tree size to
the power
log two of one plus p um
calling this a folklore result the proof
is a very simple
induction and i mean i don't know of a
reference for this but
um anyway so proof's included in the
paper
and then our main result shows that
decision list so this more powerful
model the size of decision lists shrinks
at a similar rate to decision trees so
it shrinks like decision list size of
the original function
to the power log base two over one minus
p
of one plus p over one minus p okay and
the same bound applies to d and f
formula size plus one or c in that
formula size plus one of boolean
functions
so these exponents uh that we get here
um so this is defined for all values of
p and in particular we get something
which is non-trivial for all p
less than one since these functions both
equal one when p
is one um
[Music]
and first so if the original function f
has decision list size
m this shows in particular for p being
just a constant we get
you know we shrink to expected size
something like square root of m
so um in the setting where p
is small so where p is like 1 over log m
then it was already known by the
switching lemma that the expected
decision list size is is almost a
constant and in fact
even the expected decision tree size is
at most a constant
but the switching lemma doesn't imply
anything
in the in the setting where p is
is a constant or p is close to one so
this setting is known as
sometimes called mild random
restrictions and
results in the setting are important and
have applications and de-randomization
and
boolean analysis and uh
and dnf specification
okay so to give some context for our
result it's
useful to make a distinction between
these size measures and the
corresponding width
depth measures so the
so both the hostage switching lemma
well you can you can um
frame it in terms of converting a small
width
decision list to a small depth decision
tree
and in a paper a few years ago i gave
a version of this result which replaces
decision list width with
log of decision list size
um and then so our our result in this
paper can be seen as a similar
uh has a similar relationship to a
recent uh result of loveit wu and zang
where they
prove a shrinkage result for decision
lists but in terms of the decision list
width so our
you can see our result as being along
similar lines but
replacing width with log of size
okay so the this as i mentioned this
result for decision trees
is a very simple proof by induction
which you can read on the slide
um and good so the the
the uh our
our result for decision lists is based
on um
the index function associated with uh
with a decision listen in particular
looking at
the entropy of this index function under
uniform random
point in the hypercube so the index
function is just the
the the the first index
which is which the clause ci is
satisfied
and uh right so so
we can note that um without loss of
generality the index function of l
is is subjective because if it wasn't
you could just delete any
any clause that you know where i is not
in the in the image of the index
function
and you'd be computing the same function
and so the simple observation
in love it would saying the way that
they bound expected decision list size
is by by just bounding the the expected
uh
size of the image of the index function
of the restricted decision list
um so something which right so
in the longer version of the talk i i
give a very short proof of a result
along similar lines is what we show but
something which is simpler and
the proof fits into one page showing
that the average sensitivity of a
decision list
l is bounded by twice the entropy
of the of the uh of the
index function okay so which gives a
bound of two log n
okay this is the whole proof of that
um good so just to summarize uh right
our main result was this shrinkage bound
for decision lists
so some questions this raises first of
all
it would be nice if there's some
interesting applications of this
of this result um and
this result also suggests that uh
the right notion of a shrinkage exponent
for these measures like decision trees
and
and decision lists um
is the following question so what's the
best
you know the smallest constant c such
that the expected decision list size of
any functions at most order of the
decisionless size to the c
times p for all p and so our our results
we
have both upper and lower bounds showing
that the constant for decision lists is
between one over
over natural log of two and two over
natural log of two
so it would be interesting to pin this
down exactly
um and then um right so we
sort of settle the shrinkage of depth to
ac0 formulas
and for higher depths we conjecture that
the
the shrinkage of depth d formula size
would look like the
depth d formula size raised to the order
of p
to the one over d minus one okay
okay thank you
thank you then uh
all right so maybe we should have a
regular
setup and in the meantime we might have
time for a quick question
um so maybe i'll
will save the questions for for the
discussion later
and ah i see sorry there's someone raise
their hand
so let's see if we can
uh hi i i had a quick query with uh
respect to the uh
uh uh projection uh
is there some uh uh hypercube
as i was just uh going through the paper
on which you are trying to project this
so i'm not not sure i got the question
but i was just thinking
uh with respect to the shrinkage
and the projection of it
so if there's some
results that also uh
caters to that
i'm right maybe i didn't didn't hear the
full question but i i heard the word
projection so
related to that
uh yesterday's talk might address this
but yeah
okay continue in the in the chat after
might be it might be
it'd be interesting to see if we can
combine both
yeah okay so let's continue to the
to the next uh talk about computation
over
uh the noisy brush broadcast channel
with malicious parties
and a regular bench would present
a dog thanks abhishek uh this is
actually a part of a series of word by
my quarters and myself on the broadcast
channel
and the broadcast channel is useful
because it models wireless communication
uh wireless communication does not need
to be motivated
i wouldn't be given this start without a
wireless connection but it is
unreliable in the sense that it can be
noisy and also
because it is involving a large
distributed system sometimes parties
fail randomly or some parties may be
malicious
and therefore we want protocols that
communicate that are resilient to
both the noise in the channel and
malicious parties
now one of these two the noise in the
channel has been well studied and we
have
the noisy broadcast channel which models
this we know matching upper and lower
bounds in some settings so it's
fairly well understood but in this paper
we introduced uh the first
result which shows how to do computation
over the broadcast channel when both
there is noise in the channel
and some of the parties are malicious so
that's the punchline let me now start
defining things
we will be talking about the n player
broadcast channel and we will
this is proposed by elgamal in 87 and we
will consider the bit exchange problem
so there are n parties
and each party has an input bit
let's say party i has an input x i and
what they want to do is they want to
communicate so that at the end of the
communication all the parties know all
the pins
now how do they communicate this well
there's communication is in synchronous
rounds in each round exactly one party
which is the speaker
here he will be broadcasting and he can
send
the same message to all of the parties
this message must be the same
and it cannot be a different message for
each party it needs to be the same
message for all other parties
if the communication is noiseless then
this message is received exactly
if the communication is noisy then there
is stochastic noise so with probability
one minus epsilon for some small epsilon
the message is received directly
independently by each party
and with probability epsilon it is start
upgrade so you receive something
um let's say unreliable now
for the bit exchange task where
everybody has a bit and they want to
know all the bits
for the noiseless days it is easy to see
that the protocol must take end rounds
everybody will take one round to send
their bid
and because it's neither does everybody
will receive it and the task will be
accomplished
but in the noisy case the first the
knife protocol that comes to mind has
n login runs if you repeat a bit login
times and the players decode by majority
then with a polynomial except for this
polynomially small probability they will
be correct and you can union bound and
say that the whole thing works with
polynomially small probability
but you can do better and this is a very
classic and very cute protocol by
gallagher in 88 where he
shows an exponential improvement instead
of i say an exponential because
what you really care about is the
communication per player which is just
this factor of log login
so it goes from n log into n log log n
and
it shows that you can do this bit
exchange problem using an exponentially
small communication of n log log n
and i would have loved to talk about
this protocol had one more time but i do
not so i've only talked about
our result um but it is known that this
is tight
this is a very technically
uh deep lower bound that was shown after
20 years that galileo's protocol is
essentially tight
and he cannot improve it by more than a
constant factor
however all of these results assume that
there are no malicious parties
and in fact dalian's protocol breaks
down even if there is one malicious
party in the system
and we ideally want to tolerate a large
transfer interaction
so when there are malicious parties when
there is only even when there's only one
malicious party the best protocol you
know is to just trivially repeat the
bitter end times
this is not affected by malicious
parties because everybody just does
their own thing
and then you just detoured by majority
and then you take a union amount
in this paper we show a quadratic
improvement again quadratic in the
communication per player
we show an n root login protocol
that solves bit exchange when there is
noise in the channel
and when up to half the parties in the
channel may be malicious
okay this is the main result it's a
quadratic improvement over
the previous protocol it is worse than
gallagher but gallery breaks down for
even one malicious player
but let me now spend a little bit of
time on saying what exactly does it mean
to compute something in the presence of
malicious player
usually when you say computation of the
broadcast channel you want all the
parties to know all the input bits but
this is
all the all the parties to output the
input bits of all the other parties
but this is not possible and this is not
possible for two reasons one
some parties are malicious so they will
never output the input bit of all the
other parties even if they perform
the protocol correctly even if they
behave like good parties at the end they
may just decide to output something
random and then you're doomed
so you cannot expect the malicious
parties to output something um
good but you also cannot expect an
honest party which is a non-malicious
party
to output the bit of a malicious body
and this is because
the malicious party suppose it has the
input zero what it can do is
it can throughout the protocol it can
behave as if it has the input one
and of course the other honest party who
doesn't know this will will
all it sees is that there is somebody
who's pretending his input is one and it
will of course output one for this party
so this again is impossibility uh so we
go for the strongest thing that is
possible what we want
is at the end of the protocol all the
honest parties
output the bid of all the other honest
parties
except with a very small failure
probability
okay this is the notion of computation
that we use our protocol is also
computationally efficient it's actually
near linear in fact i think it's
n log n or something and this is the
computational time that is needed at
each party that is enlarged n is of
course needed because you need to output
invest
but other than that we are just a login
factor away
and even aside of this result for
the bit exchange on the broadcast
channel what we want to really emphasize
is this notion of property preserving
interactive coding interactive coding is
just
a fancy term for making something
resilient to noise
and what is usually the focus in
interactive coding is to make a protocol
or something resilient to noise with a
low overhead so for example if you have
a communication protocol you want a
noise resilient communication protocol
that has
only a small communication overhead um
but you're willing to compromise on all
other aspects in this paper what we're
saying is that the noiseless thing was
end rounds
the trivial noisy thing was end login
run so it was a huge overhead but it had
other good properties it was a simple
protocol it was efficient it was
resilient to malicious parties
and it had all these nice properties
what galacto does
is he compromises on all the other nice
properties he
loses the resilience to malicious
players he's still efficient so i won't
say that but he loses the resilience to
malicious players but he does bring down
the communication from n log into n log
log
what we are saying is that this is not
really necessary you can even improve on
analog and even if you are
not compromising on the other properties
and this is what we call property
preserving interactive
coding that you not only maintain that
the task is performed correctly you also
maintain some nice properties of the
original noiseless protocol that you had
for the communication task okay
so let me now talk a little bit i think
i have one or two minutes let me talk a
little bit about the protocol
and how it works so we want to be
resilient
to malicious players and malicious
players can
behave in several ways but let us first
consider an easier then i'll consider
the
adversarial or the hardest way the easy
way is suppose a malicious player has
input zero
and he starts behaving like his input is
one suppose he were to repeat his bit
login times and instead of saying zero
login times he is just
uh or k times he's saying one k times
turns out this is an easy attack because
if he throughout behaves like
he has an input that is the complement
of this through input then he will just
output the complement and you'll be done
you cannot put anything for the
malicious party so you can just out the
compliment and you're fine
the harder thing for malicious uh for
the prototype is when the malicious
party tries to switch strategies it is
when the malicious party instead of
saying
one k times it says zero t over two
times and one k over two times
and now what fails is you cannot do any
rounding you cannot say that
i will record by majority because what
he's attacked was exactly your threshold
it doesn't matter where the threshold is
even put the same threshold it is
attacked
but let's say it has up and what he did
here was he failed your rounding scene
now you will round um to zero and one
with equal probability and this will be
bad for the protocol
and to get around this we propose uh
this new notion of error to editing
codes which are locality sensitive
so i'll talk about this notion next uh a
standard error writing code
takes a short
message so this is a small space let's
say zero into the k
to a larger space zero into the n such
that the images of all of these points
are far apart
this is the distance property of inertia
and it says that if you're identical of
course you will go to one point it's a
deterministic function and if you are
not identical then you are far apart
a locality sensitive at writing code
preserves locality it takes
um original messages that are close
together
to code words that are close together in
a larger space
but if your original messages are far
apart then your two encodings will also
be far apart
um i am hiding under there are some
issues with the
definition that arise due to the
triangle inequality which is
these two points here are as far apart
as these two points here and
in my picture these two points are close
together but the two points in yellow
and green are very far apart
there are there this is an issue you
cannot have such a clear definition
sorry you try to wrap up oh sure sorry
um you cannot have such a clean
definition um but this can be taken care
of in a nice way
and this gives us our definition um
last sentence two sentences we can start
our codes using a
random linear combination and show that
it gives us the right proof but we don't
make any claims about optimality so one
way to improve our protocol even further
is to just get better codes or show that
this do not exist
yeah let me stop with that thank you
sorry for going over time
thank you okay thanks for the great talk
uh i guess we are a bit short of the
time so let's move on to the next uh
talk by sequoia
about communication memento memory
memory less communication complexity
uh thanks obviously um hi everyone
so this is a joint work with srinivas
and arunachalam
um so yeah uh
so so before before i start talking
about uh memoryless communication
complexity let me briefly say
like a recap uh standard communication
complexity
so uh it was introduced by yao in 1979
and
in this uh uh so
here we have a game where we have two
players alice and bob they get their
own input x and y and they want to
compute this joint function
f of x y and obviously they need to
communicate
and so at each round they send
one bit at a time and the goal is to
compute the function by exchanging as
less bits as possible
for all possible x and y now note that
here alice and bob have unlimited time
and memory in the sense that
alice and bob they can compute any
function that they want locally and they
also remember
all the messages that they have seen
previously
so we ask this question what happens if
the player
players have no memory in between the
rounds
so so let me elaborate what i mean by
that uh
so we want that at every round alice
computes the next message
uh solely based on only her input x
and the message that she has received in
this round and
similar for bob so bob is going to
compute this compute the message to send
based on only his input and the message
that bob receives in
in this route and uh the second way we
differ from communication standard
communication complexity is
is via how we compute the cost so
so cost for in this model for computing
a function f
is the size of the largest message
communicated between this two player
alice and bob
um so so let me uh explain this
pictorial pictorially um
with this example so again we have alice
and bob these two players they have x
and y
now note that they have they they are in
this memoryless setting
so in the first round alice uh applies a
function f of x so she chooses this
function
f x based on her input x so this is a
deterministic function
and since it's starting she applies this
function on all zero input
and she produced the produces the first
message and then she sends the first
message and then forgets about it
now for for bob bob also chooses a
function
f y based on his input y and
this this function maps the incoming
message to the outgoing message so
he produces this outgoing message sends
this to alice
and then forgets about it so so they
keep on doing this
and at some point we need to stop
somewhere so we say that okay if ever
any player receives a message which
looks like something like this
where we have all zero uh with the
trailing b the output b
so uh and and we want this b to be the
function value f of x y
um now and and we we need this to be
true for all possible x and y
um so so intuitively what is happening
is in this setting we want that
so it is basically the size of a
rewritable message register
that the players send back and forth in
order to compute the function for all
possible x and y
now i have a really nice story that goes
really well with this
with this setting but maybe i'll i'll
keep it for the
discussion session now
now let's see how how this model fits
with the other space bounded uh
communication complexity model that we
have seen in
in recent years so here i will
i'll describe three models that we have
seen uh recently
the first one is garden hose model it
was introduced by burma natal in 2013.
uh in in this model alice and bob they
they they
compute this function in really this
this nice playful way
they have few pipes and they have hoses
they make the connection based on their
inputs
and then they run water and based on
like on which side the water
ends up uh they decide on the function
value
uh the second variant uh that we have
seen is uh
is is is uh um is the space bounded
communication complexity
that was introduced by broady adele in
2013
and here the player still sends one bit
at a time
but the restriction is that now they are
bounded by
only sn amount of memory and obviously
the goal is to
optimize on the on the space that that
they are allowed to have
the third variant is called overlay
communication complexity it was
introduced by papa
hotel in 2014 and this setting looks
looks pretty close to our setting that
we consider
so here the only difference is that here
atlas has
could have unlimited memory and bob
doesn't have any memory so at each round
alice sends a message and bob could just
either output 0 or 1 or continue and
they need to compute the function in
this way
so what we did is we came up with this
this relation
so here let's decipher it a little bit
uh
here nm stands for uh no memory so this
is the memoryless communication
complexity that we consider so it's the
cost of computing any function in that
in that model gh stands for guardians
complexity
and this is the space bounded complexity
introduced by brody
brady adele and this is the overlay
complexity
so what we what we showed using this
framework is that
this three models are essentially the
same
and furthermore they are also upper
bounded by the overlay complexity so in
in that sense
uh this memoryless complexity gives us a
framework of seeing like how all the
space-bounded complexity models are
connected
but but moreover it also helped us uh
finding
uh better algorithms for the gardeners
model so for instance
we had these two problems uh one is
disjointness with
quadratic universe and the other problem
is indirect storage axis problem so this
is like
x x of y of z and for both of this
problem it was conjectured that
the gardener's complexity has to be like
omega n square
but for the first problem using this
connection so since since it's upper
bounded by overlay complexity so you can
we can use an algorithm for this model
to come up with an algorithm here
uh we could reduce it slightly uh
but on the other hand using this
connection you
using this memoryless communication
complexity we could actually get a
linear protocol for the indirect storage
access problem so
so so so all these things and and there
is also uh some non-trivial thing that
we could say about
space bounded communication complexity
that couldn't be seen seen before
just by folding uh studying this this
model
so so for instance so so we can we could
probably say that memory less
communication complexity model
is perhaps a cleaner framework for
studying all the space boundary
communication complexity model
um so so now like okay can we come up
with some characterization of this
memory less communication complexity
model like
we know that standard communication
complexity we do this uh
rectangle partition so so what is
happening here since since the players
do not have
memory and it turns out that uh
memory less communication complexity can
be characterized in terms of
bipartite branching program now a
bipartite branching program differs from
a normal branching program in this way
that so here you are seeing one example
of a
branching program the only difference is
that nodes are labeled by
instead of variables x0 it could be
labeled by a function
which is either computing on x or
computing on y so it could be a function
on x or function and y so it
it has this distribution distributed
nature
um so so this bipartite branching
program is
actually characterizes uh this
memoryless communication complexity
setting
um we could also uh show connection with
formula size so
uh we showed that any formula size s
consisting of arbitrary fan into
can be turned into a memoryless protocol
of size 1 plus epsilon
log log s or arbitrary epsilon now
now this says that it basically provides
a new way of proving formula size lower
bounds for arbitrary functions
uh by analyzing the memoryless protocol
for for the function so it has
um in it it has the same essence of the
customers with dust and game where
uh so so here we are basically
in order to prove a formula size lower
bound we could instead just study this
uh fun form function in the memory list
a second
but one thing to note that here constant
really matters in the sense that
if we prove a log and lower bond versus
the two log and lower bound this should
be treated
differently so for instance if we prove
a log and lower bound that would give us
a n formula size lower bond
on the other hand 2 log n would actually
give us a n square lower bound so so
constant really matters
in this model okay so finally uh i would
describe some open problems so
there could be several open problems
because it's a new new model
but the main uh open problem is basic is
to prove a
lower bound of some some explicit
function in the memoryless model
which would be c times log n for for
some c which is strictly greater than
one so we could prove c
equal to one over one first explicit
function but c
strictly greater than one would actually
imply uh three things
it would actually imply two things first
of all you could imply a super linear
lower bound
for guardians model which is open it
would also imply
super linear lower bond for the
bipartite branching program which is
which is also not known
and proving something better than 2 plus
epsilon because of this formula size
lower bound connection
would actually give omega n to the 2
plus epsilon lower bond for the general
formula size and this is
this the best is from najib from 1966.
so so yeah and we think that for
for this for this uh c strictly greater
than one one candidate could be this
distributed
three click function um yeah so so i i
would i would stop
with uh maybe spending like 10 seconds
on this that
we also defined like quantum version of
different variants of uh
memoryless model and we could we could
uh prove like exponential separation
between the classical and the quantum
quantum counterpart
so yeah i um so i'll stop here you can
look at this link for the full version
on also the
full talk is there thank you thank you
so much thank you
thank you for the great talk um okay so
let's move on to the uh
final talk by elon
can you share your screen yeah
can you tell me if you see a slide yeah
yeah we can see the slides
uh okay so elon kumar godziki will tell
us about differentially oblivious turing
machines
oh hi everyone so yeah i'll tell you
about differentiable steering machines
i'm milan komagatki and this is based on
joint work with
elaine shea so the motivation for
this work is the following
well-known fact by today that even if
you
encrypt your database and you send it to
somebody else
think of the cloud for that matter then
it's insecure once you start making
accesses to the
your database namely just by looking at
where you access your data
even not knowing what's written inside
the database a lot of sensitive
information might leak and this is a
problem that
was observed already in the late 80s and
early 90s
by goldberg and ostrovsky that
introduced the influential
concept of oblivious ram an oblivious
ram is just
this very nice useful
approach it's just an algorithm that
whose task is to obfuscate the access
pattern of algorithms
and slightly more precisely or a bit
less precisely what it does
uh is that it it takes the
the access patterns of an algorithm and
it sort of encrypts them
something like analogous to what
encryption does to messages
and slightly more mathematically what it
does is
it makes the access pattern of of
algorithms
look independent of the underlying data
what do i mean by
being independent independent of the
data so there are naturally
many ways to define it uh three very
common ways
just define computationally distinguish
independence meaning that
in a computationally bound the attacker
will not
know by looking at the access patterns
anything about the underlying data
there's a statistical variant which
allows the distinguisher to
be computationally unbounded and there's
even a perfect version
where the attacker is unbounded and
the distinguisher or the attacker is
unbounded and
it has no advantage whatsoever so this
is what the oblivious round
is and it usually works in the following
way all of the constructions
follow the same pattern they first
preview the data in the memory in some
way and then
upon every access to the data they
reshuffled it this is how
aura works classically and
so the fate of the art of auram is
pretty has pretty
much solved or advanced since the
introduction
of this problem about 30 years ago so by
now we know essentially that any program
any random program that you give me i
can make it oblivious
or i can make it i can make it a
different program
or that implements the same
functionality with just
very small overhead in terms of the
amount of access that you need to make
so for example if you give me a ram that
works on n
cells with n memory cells then i can
simulate every single access to the
memory with something like
lobe accesses to the to the memory and
assuming one way functions the
construction will be computationally
secure
if we want statistical security then we
need to make something like log squared
accesses for every axis
so this is a pretty great and it's also
great because we have matching lower
bounds
so we know that logarithmic overhead is
necessary so
there's nothing we can do to improve on
this and
something very surprising is that this
logarithmic overhead
is necessary even for very specific
functionalities so even if you
consider very simple algorithmic tasks
or data structures
we already know that for them if you
want to make them oblivious
we need logarithmic overhead in the
amount of accesses that we make
so this is the state of of the art for
aurum constructions
and a couple of years ago uh
chen italian introduced a meaningful
relation
of obliviousness in exactly in order to
see if we can go below the logarithmic
overhead
so they introduced a notion that they
termed differential obliviousness
and the name comes from the concept of
differential privacy
you'll see in a couple of slides when i
define it why why
why it's inspired made
but then a year later there was a very
surprising result showing that even if
you consider this
significant relaxation it's a very
strong relaxation of security it
guarantees much less about privacy than
the cost of a general aura
or a general general differentially
oblivious ram
is still logarithmic this was a very
surprising result
but for specific functionalities
we can actually do much much better if
we consider differential obliviousness
than obliquezness
so for instance we have tests we know
tasks that the best construction that we
have
which satisfies full obliviousness
requires logarithmic overhead
while if we settle for the weaker notion
of differential obliviousness
then we can obtain it with doubly
logarithmic overhead
let me try to define what differentiable
business is
so let's first talk about the setting or
the model
so the setting consists of the cpu it's
this green box in the middle of the
screen
the cpu can be randomized it has a
source of randomness
and the input for the cpu is a sequence
of logical accesses
it could be any algorithm that you run
or any data structure that you execute
in the translated to a sequence of
inputs to your
ram the cpu gets those
uh accesses those logical accesses and
translates them into physical accesses
and the attacker is viewing those it
tries to learn something about your
input
so since we're talking about
differential oblique business
which is similar to the differential
privacy
we'll consider a neighbor a neighboring
input sequence
which is an identical sequence of
operations
of logical operations except that we're
going to change one location
so just in this example i change the s3
from the end
the third from the end um access
to be something else so these two inputs
are
neighboring and what we want is that if
we execute the left
experiment or the right experiment then
they will be indistinguishable
and what do i mean by distinguishable so
it's the same definition as in
differential privacy
what we want is that the probability
that
you see the left sequence of
physical accesses it's very close to the
probability that you'll see the right
sequence of activities the blue sequence
of axises
except that there's this e to the
epsilon multiplicative factor
and an additive delta factor so this is
the definition of differential
obliviousness
and here's our result it's just one
slide
what we show is that essentially any
turing machine computation
can be made differentially oblivious
with doubly logarithmic
overhead in runtime so let me parse out
the result so consider a turing machine
computation
that runs in n-steps any turing machine
it has
you know this tape and it has a head the
head can move left and right
and assume that your computation makes n
steps
so and movements to in some direction
every movement is to some direction
there's a very famous result from the
late 70s by peeping jordan fisher
showing that any turing machine can be
made
fully oblivious so it can be made such
that
it's completely independent of the
underlying input or program that you
execute
with logarithmic overhead this is like a
very famous and influential result from
back in the 70s we showed that if you
settle for the weaker notion of
differential obliviousness
you can do it generically with only
doubly logarithmic overhead
and we also know that there is
we also showed that there is a lower
bound the matching lower bound for our
upper bound so that the logarithmic
overhead is necessary
our lower bound is in this restricted
model which is called the bulging beams
model
where there's where the cpu whether
the server cannot really look at your
the elements that you store but it can
only see them as a pack balls
so it's a it's a weak model for a lower
bound but it's still a lower bound
and we actually know that there is a
lower bound for
full obliviousness though there is no
construction that
that improves on beef injury and fissure
if we want the full
like if you want full pledge
obliviousness and this
follows from the work i mentioned
earlier and this holds for very simple
tasks like attack
we just want to make a stack oblivious
it plus logarithmic overhead but if you
want to make it differentially oblivious
we can do it with
doubly logarithmic overhead and a lot of
technical effort in this work
is devoted to preserving the various
properties of the
turing machine that is given to us so we
can handle multi-tape turing machines
and we want to preserve preserve that
number and we want to preserve the
alphabet size and
lots of other things related to turing
machines
and one implication of this result is
that differential obliqueness is
uh strictly weaker than obliviousness
until
until this separation there was no
separation between there was no
evidence that differential obliviousness
is easier to achieve in the
obliviousness even though it looks
significantly weaker
so this is our result uh we use two
tools
i won't have a lot of time to tell you
how the construction works but
just in one sentence the tools that we
use
we use an oblivious turing machine you
can think about
the one of you can join the feature for
that model even though we need to
tweak it a little bit and the second
tool that we develop
is a turing machine that estimates
the location of the head of another
turing machine
uh while maintaining differential
privacy
of that estimate that's the main
technical
thing that we develop and this is where
i'm gonna finish
thank you thank you and
i want to salute elon for giving the
talk at 2 30
a.m in israel time so yes that's pretty
impressive
um okay so let's let's open the the
floor for questions to
all speakers and i know that i have a
bunch of questions but uh
you know feel free to um to unmute
yourself or raise your hand
or you can also ask questions in the q a
if you want
um hi uh um yeah
uh i had a query uh uh with respect to
the
memory uh footprint so
what's the uh optimal memory footprint
for this
algorithm uh which for the uh overhead
that you
uh achieved yeah it's constant
yeah the global memory is constant okay
okay so uh uh the
scalability if i um look at it from a
distribution perspective those uh
scalability issues won't be a
okay uh uh with
respect to the algorithm uh the
uh you mean the con the data
there's only one parameter there's only
the number of steps that the turing
machine
does
[Music]
would be depending on the input it could
not depend on the input
so there's only one yeah yeah i agree
there's only one parameter but
from the practical perspective uh um
of saving those stack in the memory
ah so i was thinking more in terms of
the
uh you know
so we have only constant overhead in the
memory size uh
so it shouldn't cost you too much and
the constants are pretty small
okay i didn't implement it but it seemed
like smaller than 10 maybe
so do you have some uh uh empirical
um results uh associated with this
we didn't implement this unfortunately
okay thank you
okay thanks
i wonder so this notion of uh you know
near
neighboring uh sequences are we refer to
the
head movements right yes what about
the notion of like neighboring inputs
did you consider that as well
so it's really hard to define because
neighboring inputs
might translate to extremely different
movements right so
and it doesn't really make sense to
maintain privacy when
once you like your two instances one is
go left and the other is go right a
bazillion steps like i can't really hide
which input you're
you're using right okay
yeah it's really impossible to do
anything
there's one thing that i didn't say at
the end of time is that
when i talk about neighboring inputs i
only talked about one location
that differs but you can actually
generalize it using uh
you know group theorems uh differential
privacy group theorems
generically so you can you lose
something in the bounds but
it generalizes very nicely
i mean how many uh modification
can you get before you hit the log you
know then again
you can always do it within logan no
matter how many changes you have
which no so you're losing privacy you
don't lose in
complexity okay um
so so i need to think about the
dependence on epsilon and delta
and
[Music]
i need to need to calculate okay because
there is dependence on epsilon and delta
and epsilon is a constant
delta is an equilibrium function so
i need to just look at the equation it's
not hard to work at
um can i ask a quick question of a
previous speaker
for raghuvanch i wanted to ask you about
the concept of property preserving
interactive coding
i just wanted to ask do you mean it
preserves the specific properties you
mentioned
such as resilience to malicious
adversary or do you have some general
definition of somehow
preserving all properties or is it a
formal notion
that you're talking about it's not
formal it's just we take
a noiseless protocol we see that the
noise protocol has low communication
plus it may have some properties that we
want to preserve
and the goal is to design a protocol
that is resoluted noise while preserving
uh the properties we wanted it's not
that any protocol for the original thing
will be preserved
for example one property is that it has
communication and
and you have sure so we select some
properties and it's more
ad hoc transformation that preserves
what we wanted to
got it and can i also ask a very quick
question about
just the definition not for touring
machines but the general definition of
differential
obliviousness uh let's say it was ram
where you have two sequences does it
matter for the definition
if the sequence is adaptive or not
adaptive or does it not really matter
so for the definition or i mean because
if you say if
if you change the third from the last
but somehow it might depend on the
answer what will happen
next no it should not
matter i think the lower bound
[Music]
does not do that like we have a lower
bound right that's the
only result we have that's meaningful
and that one doesn't even use the
property that you just mentioned
the sequence is completely fixed there
except like one thing
and then if i wish i still here the
answer is that
um yeah i can tolerate
a group of size log so it means that
only things that are like
logo part and not just distance one you
can try to go here
yeah thanks it
degrades exponentially with epsilon so
uh okay great i i i really enjoyed all
the talks um
um i have a question for for shivan
um so so
first i mean you mentioned that you know
the analog with
uh telegrams result and uh you mentioned
this
it was right but i didn't get uh
whether your result is that whether you
know that it cannot
so we don't think it's tight um and
in particular we think you know that
actually can i put my slides back up
sure yeah um
yeah uh so we we believe that you know
something similar over here should hold
but with telegrams
c function not not our free function
it's like we we still have this
additional logarithmic factor
and uh telegrams exam telegram's result
is tight for two hamming balls
of like correctly chosen volumes um
and our result from like the conjectured
optimal result with just the log factor
over here that supposedly looks great
uh we have two sets which match that
match that conjunction plan so yeah we
like
in the logarithmic covers and within
logarithmic fact of
the optimal okay thanks and and another
question
uh i mean you you you sort of showed
these results one next to the other is
there any formal connection between
these results
um what do you mean i mean between you
know the correlation of monotone
boolean functions and also symmetry
convex but
bodies under the gaussian measure
i'm not sure if i'm following your
question are you asking if there's like
a way to go from like a monitor and
boolean function to a synaptic convex
space yeah is there like a formal
connection between these questions or is
it just an
inspiration yeah it's sort of an analogy
there's no formal connection um
but like some some things seem to hold
like you know dictators
over the boolean hypercube seem to
correspond to slabs
you know slabs such as um
sorry slides on this is it's weird it's
frozen
um or or um
things like you know majority seems to
correspond to the sphere
so there seems to be there seem to be
many analogies but there's no formal
connection
okay yeah and maybe uh
another question is are there any
application of this
new quantitative correlation inequality
i don't know of any parallel
applications uh to be to be completely
honest i'm not sure
what applications of telegram's result
exists i mean there's many theoretical
implications right like telegrams
techniques like his main lemma is used
to prove many things in
boolean functional analysis like the big
chaos theorem um
so again like i'm not not sure if
there's a direct application
of these quantitative coordination
inequalities i might be wrong
thank you
again anybody feel free to to ask
questions to any of the speakers
i guess i have a stupid question um
so so i i also worked on interactive
coding a little bit but i've always
wondered like is there
has anyone tried to like implement or
deploy interactive coding protocols like
this is for the last but second speaker
um um sorry can you please repeat your
question
i i was just saying like i've always
wondered if anyone has tried to like
actually implement or deploy interactive
coding any type of interactive coding
protocols
like has this line not work and been
considered like for
for any type of implementation or usage
like
yeah is this question you referred to a
regular venge maybe
yeah yeah sure sorry i'm
so stupid sorry no
people said that i thought this was for
me but i was not sure
um so one application i know of
is the application to uh resilience
circuits it's not like an actual
deployment of anything but it
it is an application of the theory to
another aspect of theory the problem
there is suppose you have a formula
or let's say formula not a circuit and
you know that some of the dates in the
formula can have errors but you still
want the formula to compute the same
function
um then what you can do is there's the
starch pervaders and transformation that
takes a formula to
uh circuit sorry to a communication
protocol
you can run interactive coding on the
communication protocol and then you can
transform it back to a noise-resistant
formula
so that is one connection i know i do
not
know of any actually engineering
applications of this
area
okay thanks
if we if you are asking questions uh
about about
uh your talk i have a bunch of questions
so um
so just a clarification questions
regarding the malicious parties i
i guess i didn't really understand maybe
the the framework like
in particular is it clearing every round
who's speaking and can the malicious
party
inter interfere and if so that seems a
little bit
that's actually a great question because
like when we were when we wrote the
paper i i would have given one answer to
this question but now i can give another
answer to this question
so let's see in general in our protocol
we do not assume anything from malicious
party we just
uh assume that it can do whatever it
wants
um but therefore when what when we're
when we're defining the model in the
paper we assume that
for every round you know who's speaking
in that realm and this is because if you
do not know this and you allow the
parties the freedom to speak whenever
they want then the malicious parties can
just keep talking in every round and
they will not allow any attempt they
will just like
choke the channel and not allow any
communication to take place
um so this model and our protocol is
non-adaptive and non-adaptive is exactly
what i said for every round you know who
is speaking in that round
and our result is for the non-adapter
thing there there is the adaptive
broadcast channel
and in the paper i'm not sure we said
this but at least we were thinking okay
this definition is clearly breaking down
and you cannot have malicious
and adaptivity at the same time but now
we have a model that does this and the
model turns out to be
that you do not assume that the parties
are malicious
instead you assume that they fail i
think this is the right generalization
when you have a
when you have an adaptive channel then
the parties will just not be talking
they will not talk even when they're
supposed to
and it is
it is not clear like at least all the
protocols we know of will not carry over
even if the parties fail
and it is an interesting problem to
define uh such a protocol
okay thank you very interesting and what
about like if you allow them
to interfere but in a bounded way like
you know
in our correcting code we usually
usually assume adversarial
noise but under some budget like you can
corrupt most epsilon fraction of the
okay so that's another great question oh
my god so many great questions
uh so when you have a distributed system
then actually you should really read the
paper because we cover all of these
questions but anyway
when you have a distributed system then
it turns out that adversarial noise
tends to be um
i don't know what's the word but like
notorious because what you can do is if
you have n parties and even if you have
a one over n fraction of adversarial
noise
you can just focus it on one of the end
parties and then because that party is
not speaking then you cannot just
compute the
identity or the biggest change problem
and
usually uh we have it's not that it
wasn't studied it was studied in
distributed settings but usually the
results go like okay you clearly fail
when you have one over
n um adversarial noise but what the
result says is that as long as you have
less than one over n let's say you have
one over 10 and adversarial noise
then the protocol will work correctly in
the paper we
take inspiration from our definition
from malicious players to give a new
definition
of correctness for adversarial noise and
the definition goes like
this you have some let's say even a
constant fraction of adversarial noise
so the adversary can kill a constant
fraction of the players
let's say it's point zero one for
configuration so one percent of
adversarial noise
um but what we want is instead of being
correct for all the players we allow
us we allow the protocol to fail on a
constant fraction of the players as well
and again this is another like
ideological
uh sorry conceptual contribution of this
paper that gives you a definition for
adversarial noise that does not have the
one over and bottleneck um
and basically can regard the parties
that were choked by the adversary that
were bullied by the adversary as being
malicious and now you want the protocol
that is turret on the remaining parties
you can even get some slack you can even
say that if the adversarial fraction is
one percent i'm allowing you to kill
five percent of the parties just give me
something to start on 95
um so there is also that there's room
there
these are all great questions and this
is all
like future work yeah
it's maybe a future word maybe there is
no word
okay um
uh okay i have some questions
for ben ben are you still around
yeah hi so uh you mentioned
some possible motivation coming from
you know mild random restrictions we're
using in surrounding generators by
the famous work of gmriv
[Music]
do you see do you see any any potential
you know the randomization of this uh of
this result
uh i know that recently
uh you know uh sandra kelly randomized
one of your
results and so
yeah i'm i'm not sure so the short
answer is i haven't
i haven't thought about it exactly but
i'm um
[Music]
so i mean a lot of the results use
you know look at width as opposed to psi
so i'm not sure what the
uh yeah i'm not sure what the potential
applications might might be in this case
and do you think that
do you think that there's like that the
results don't say something on
or they say something only on size and
not on weed
and trying to understand the outcome
um so the the width version of this
of this result is in the is in this
paper of love it went
that i mentioned um but
yeah no really i'm just i'm i'm not sure
i'd have to look uh
i haven't thought much about the
potential applications and
de-randomization i i tried thinking if
this might have
applications to things like uh main
source conjecture
or specification not so much about the
deranimization
yeah yeah great open questions one thing
that comes to mind is you know random
restrictions
uh naturally composes right if i do a
pure under restriction then a q random
restriction it's just a p times q random
restriction
and then it seems natural that the
bounds that you would get would also
compose nicely so
based on that is it does it
give rise to a natural conjecture of the
right behavior
so it uh right good so that that that
shows that the bound you get should be
convex so this this exponent uh
um this this log base whatever
this this exponent is convex and if it
wasn't you could make it so by
by taking compositions but let's see
all right uh just a quick
uh follow-up uh so the projections
that you are taking i was just um
wondering uh which uh algorithm
um did you take into account i might
have
missed that
see um
[Music]
not still not sure i understand the
question but maybe
just to clarify so ben's result is with
respect to
random restrictions where you you pick
each coordinate you keep it alive with
some probability
and let's say p and with probability one
minus p you flip a random
bit and you set it to this constant
but uh those uh uh uh projections have
to be taken into account
uh since you need to uh weekly assume
those
probabilities into a particular uh
objective so i was just just thinking
uh those weekly
or i might be
missing it i don't know correct me if
i'm wrong
here yes
yeah i'm still not sure exactly what's
what's being asked
um so in in the paper of avishai
or in uval they they introduces
a generalization of random restrictions
in fact they can be projections
uh it's it's actually interesting if if
those could be made to work in this yeah
in this argument
oh okay okay uh okay good thanks
all right any any more questions to any
of the speakers
i guess we are going to be late already
but
i had a question for uh sasha actually
if he's still around
uh sure sure yeah so if i understand
the result correctly you have you say
you know
one would like to prove circuit lower
bounds by saying look
if circuits of a certain depth can be
reduced to constant depth with a certain
size
and so you say well here's something
that works on any depth
and it just depends on the size right
but
the size that you get at the constant
depth is
is very large hopefully not too large
that you can't prove anything and so
you're looking for lower bounds
to turn it into an actual lower bound
you'd need a lower bound on that
constant depth
right um do you what
what techniques do you think are you do
you have a particular technique in mind
that you think could be extended
to those kinds of uh constant depth uh
but very large size
circuits um to prove lower bounds for
this um
or you know where um how do you think
this would be turned into
a lower bound for a you know a natural
problem or any problem
yeah yeah so no that's a that's an
amazing question and luckily we have
tens of results that are proving
very strong chlorobonds for say depth
with circuits
like really strong just a little weaker
than what we need covalent result for
our result uh
to to to definitely circular amount so
in fact we have tons of techniques
just somehow magically currently they
don't
they don't give a result that we need
but
no i don't think there is a lack of
techniques so essentially we have a
bunch of techniques for proven there's
three
um circle we have a bunch of different
techniques
for proving dispersal of robots and they
would also lead to
to the needed uh depth relevant
techniques
same things with the gdcr correlations
polynomials i think these techniques are
quite different but they
all would lead to depth three circuit
lower bound so
yeah but we have quite a few okay thank
you
i had a quick uh query with uh
um porter so uh if he is on the call
yeah yeah uh i was thinking why did you
use
um um bipartite
um branching programs
here as uh the the
communication mo the
characteristic of your communication
model couldn't you have modeled it
uh in some other data structure
and if so so uh
what were your other considerations
uh right um i think my
bipartite branching program came pretty
naturally because this is how the model
looks because if you
look at like uh like these two players
they're sending messages back and forth
and
uh if you look at like any run of uh
of of this game for particular x and y
you you'll see that
um any player cannot send the same
message twice because otherwise they
don't have memory they'll run into
infinite loop uh so it has this acyclic
nature and it also this bipartite in the
sense that because
um like some messages are coming from
alice and some messages are coming from
wall
so so when you try to plug this thing as
a graph
it naturally gives you a bipartite
branching program because
um you start with this like the alice
always start with this particular
particular node you can you can think of
like they always start with a particular
node and then it's just
walking um along this acyclic graph so
so yeah
it's like natural uh
yeah generalization that that happens
from this game
awesome thanks yeah i have another
question regarding the model so so
in the model you you only
consider focused on the memory
uh you know complexity
and not on the number of rounds uh
what what happens if we take into
account both of them and do we know that
the model
changes dramatically yeah so there are
like uh it's possible to prove like
um uh like time-space trade-off theorem
like for instance you you could say like
uh if you if you restrict
round to be uh like let's say constant
or something
then it can be you can show that then we
can prove like super linear
uh like super logarithmic lower bound
and
there could be like hierarchy theorems
based on like what can we achieve using
let's say k
round versus k plus one round yeah we
didn't do that but yeah that's
that's a possibility actually okay great
thanks
and maybe another question so you
mentioned this connection to formula
and you said that you know but by what
you can
prove now you can prove like a uh linear
lower bound formulas but we know
quadratic robots are formulas so did you
consider just the
the function introduced by the g baruch
yeah so uh no linear in the sense that
like if we have let's say
in in in memory less communication
complexity if we if you prove like cv
login lower bound
then that would translate as uh into the
c lower bound
so in order to get anything meaningful
we need to prove at least two plus
epsilon lower bond
then because it's a translation from
like general formula
so yeah for formula it has to be at
least like two plus epsilon
times log and lower bound right so i got
that so
but my question is you know what happens
like if you look at the
uh problem that proved the n squared
lower bound for
in your model uh
[Music]
yeah um yeah i i think like
uh najib proved one of the thing was
this in indirect storage access
uh so we get like a linear lower bound
actually if you if you try to go
via this direction because here uh
there is a there is a very simple login
login
uh size protocol i see yeah yeah so it's
it's uh um
so the connection to formula is sort of
one way it's not uh
that's right yeah it's one way it's not
it's not too way sorry my
life yeah okay
great thanks everybody for the great
talks
and i guess uh it's getting uh late so i
won't uh
keep you away from uh you know getting
some rest
uh so see you and thank you very much